Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
ein bisschen
Kansalp.
Was für ein Wunder.
So Leute, ich bin am starten!
Ich versuche gerade nebenbei noch ein Video freizuschalten.
Allerdings ist mein Browser der Meinung, er muss sich updaten und updaten nicht und starten nicht.
Auch geil.
So, heute spielen wir wieder ein bisschen Battlefield 3.
Battlefield 3 Master Race.
Ähm, wer mitspielen will, und das ist zwingend notwendig, dass Leute mitspielen, sonst kann man nämlich nicht spielen.
Kann auf meinen Battlefield 3 Server kommen, Ausrufezeichen Server im Chat.
Oder halt einfach das anklicken, was ich gerade im Chat, was der Bot gerade im Chat geschrieben hat.
WP, was, WWPD.
Max habe ein privates Problem, bei dem mir eventuell jemand mit mehr Lebenserfahrung helfen kann. Willst du mir helfen?
Ob ich will, entscheide ich nachdem du mir erklärt hast, um was es geht.
Ja, schieß los, was, was ist das Problem?
Was, was liegt an?
So, wenn jetzt natürlich das Video demnächst mal der Meinung ist, verarbeitet zu sein, dann kann ich das auch noch freischalten.
Weil ich dachte mir, das ist ein gutes Timing, wenn ich jetzt eh anfange zu streben.
Kann ich auch zeitgleich das Video freischalten, dass Leute, die quasi im Video auf den Stream klicken, die kommen dann quasi bei einem laufenden Stream raus.
Was geht eigentlich bei YouTube ab, wer designt denn diese YouTube Oberfläche?
Die ist die letzten Jahre, ich will nicht sagen durch und durch schlechter geworden, aber viel unübersichtlicher.
Wisst ihr, was mir auf YouTube auch richtig auf den Keks geht?
Wenn man jetzt auf den Channel von jemand geht und sagt zum Beispiel, hey, mich würde mal interessieren, was war denn sein aller, aller erstes Video?
Dann gehst du da drauf und musst erstmal gefühlt eine halbe Stunde nach unten scrollen, weil es hier kein Scrollbar mehr gibt, sondern das alles so dynamisch nachlädt und sowas.
Du kannst nicht einfach einfach sagen, so ich klicke jetzt auf Seite 1 und da ist dein erstes Video.
Hopp, das geht nicht.
Also wäre zu einfach.
Wie fandest du gestern den deutschen Overwatch-Cast?
Ich finde Cami und Cyrus machen das gut.
Was ich mir wünschen würde ist, dass noch ein bisschen mehr...
Das soll nicht geflamed sein, deswegen muss ich mir jetzt überlegen, wie ich das...
Ich bin froh, dass wir überhaupt in Deutschland welche haben, die das machen.
Und sich da anscheinend auch soweit mit Blizzard verstehen, dass das funktioniert.
Ich würde mir noch ein bisschen mehr Knowledge über die Pro-Szene wünschen in Overwatch.
Zum Beispiel, was überhaupt nicht erwähnt wurde ist...
Und vor allem Cyrus, dem war überhaupt nicht klar, dass das der Fall ist.
Sonst hätte er wahrscheinlich nicht auf 1-2-3 als Sieger getippt beim zweiten Match.
1-2-3 hat mit Ersatz gespielt.
Das war im Vorfeld bekannt.
Die Antonic, da hat kein Visa gekriegt.
Und das wäre eine gute Information gewesen, auch für die Zuschauer, warum auf einmal 1-2-3 so chancenlos abgekackt hat.
Obwohl sie eigentlich viel besser sind.
Ansonsten denke ich mir, manchmal vielleicht nicht ganz so schnell, dafür ein bisschen detaillierter.
Aber das ist Style.
Nee, das ist nicht gedacht, das ist nur, weil ich im Winter-Modus bin.
Und ich bin im Winter-Modus, weil ich gerade im anderen Fenster rumklicke.
Aber komm mal, wir haben schon einen Gegner.
Ja, also Leute, wer mitspielende, machen wir mal hier Ausrufezeichen-Server.
Übrigens, es gab einen Battlefield-3-Patch, hat zumindest Origen gesagt.
Hatte ich das auch.
Aber Killerson insgesamt finde ich das gut, dass die beiden das machen und die machen das auch gut.
Den Chat, dass man den Chat quasi nicht mit dem englischen Channel vergleichen kann, finde ich ein bisschen schade.
Weil ein bisschen mehr Action im Chat, bzw. einfach ein bisschen mehr Game-basiertes, würde das auch gut tun, denke ich.
Weil es gucken 400-450 Leute zu und der Chat ist tot.
Das sackt irgendwie. Es ist nicht so die ultimative Viewer-Experience.
So, vielleicht haben wir den Server ja auch soweit voll, dass wir spielen können, bis ich mein Video freischalten kann.
Oh, mein Browser hat gehabt, krasser Shit.
Da, noch Video jetzt mal.
Oh, auf YouTube.
Moin, ESL-Bingo.
Ähm, Büffel, das stimmt, Battlefield 3 sieht richtig gut aus.
Battlefield 3 sieht richtig gut aus und das Beste ist, ich glaube, ich hab das noch nicht mal auf High.
Kommt mal, kommt mal, das ist Battlefield 3 auf Low.
Battlefield 3 auf Low sieht einfach schon mal um 3000x besser aus als das neue Gott.
Der Flickshot ist real hier.
Warum auch immer ich das jetzt mache, weiß nicht.
Weil ich darauf warte, dass ich endlich mein Video freischalten kann.
Danke für die Follows.
So, Firefox.
Darf ich jetzt auf meine, man kann jetzt ja nicht mehr einfach so auf meine Uploads klicken,
ich muss jetzt oben rechts Kanal, Creator Studio, Video Manager
und da kann man auch nicht mehr direkt in die Details, da muss man das Video anklicken
und dann geht man auf öffentlich unser Speicher.
Ja, super.
Das ist nicht so easy, wie das sein könnte.
So, perfekt.
Video freigeschaltet, jetzt muss ich das nur noch auf Twitter posten
und dann ist es aber vielleicht auch so weit, dass man spielen kann.
Ups.
Ich glaube, mein Game ist abgekackt gerade, kann das sein?
Hat mein Game gerade abgekackt?
Ich glaube, mein Game ist abgekackt, auch gut.
Dann muss ich Battlefield 3 nochmal beenden.
BF, BF3, wo ist es?
Zack, aus und nochmal neu starten.
Jetzt posten wir noch das Video und dann geht's los.
Die Musik von der Lautstärke, das war angenehm.
Ich hab nämlich schon, nachdem ich den Stream ein paarmal Probe gehört, hab ich es mir aufgefallen,
die Lautstärke für mich, wie ich hier irgendwas in-game höre und Musik höre,
ist komplett anders, wie das, wie es im Stream ankommt.
Einfach komplett, kann man überhaupt nicht vergleichen.
Battlefield starten, hallo?
Go, go.
Damn.
So, auf Leute, brauche Mitspieler.
Sonst wird das nix.
Ist Battlefield 3 dein Lieblingsbattlefield?
Ich würde sagen, das teilt sich den Platz mit Bad Company 2.
Wobei, es ist vielleicht noch ein Ticken vor Bad Company 2.
Aber nicht viel, nicht viel.
Was ist denn euer Lieblingsbattlefield, wenn wir gerade bei dem Thema sind?
Ups, mein Chat ist abgekackt.
Was ist jetzt los?
Ups, das hätte nicht passieren dürfen.
Ja, FireFox, da hab ich dir Recht.
Ich kann halt keinen Chat lesen, weil der Chat ist weg.
So, jetzt Chat ist wieder da.
Max, liest du oben?
Ja, Moment, hab ich ganz, ganz übersehen.
WWPD, hab ich doch gesagt, schieß los, was das Problem ist.
Falls du's noch geschrieben hast, dann schreib's wieder nochmal, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Schreib einfach mal, was du, was hast du denn für Sorgen?
Ja, ich bin da immer hin und her gerissen zwischen Bad Company 2 und Battlefield 3.
Wobei, Battlefield 3 ist ein Ticken weiter vorne, würde ich sagen.
Ein Ticken, nicht viel.
Nicht viel.
Ich bin gemässer.
Wildes Gemässerer.
RPG und Inf.
Gilt das jetzt als Boosten?
So, wie viele Spieler fehlen noch?
Also laut Admin-Konsole sind 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Leute schon drin.
Das heißt, die Runde müsste eigentlich starten.
Ja, geht's, geht's.
Achtung Leute, ich zeig euch jetzt mal was.
Ich wollte schon die ganze Zeit richtig schießen.
Wir machen jetzt ein paar Trickshots.
Kannst mich Trickshots machen.
Ich hab's doch gelesen.
Du hast nichts geschrieben.
Ich hab doch gesagt, schreiben wurde das Problem, ich wusste auch zuhören.
Du schießt nur und schreibt, er versteht nicht, warum Battlefield 3 kein Remake bekommt.
Ich will kein Remake von Battlefield 3, sondern ich hätte gerne ein neues Spiel, quasi im Geiste von Battlefield 3.
Das wäre gut.
Ich seh das nicht, BWPD, ich seh nur, dass du gefragt hast, ob du mich was fragen kannst, mehr seh ich nicht.
Ich glaub, das ist die Rolle.
Das war schön offen, war trotzdem gut inszeniert, hatte Charaktere, die irgendwie lustig waren, das hat sich nicht so ernst genommen.
Company 2 hat sich schon fast wieder zu ernst genommen.
Okay, dann les ich das mal. Darf ich das vorlesen, was du mir da geschrieben hast?
Okay, das muss ich jetzt mal durchlesen.
Jetzt gibt es hier Lebensberatung, Max FPS.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Spiel jetzt der richtige Ort ist, so was zu besprechen, aber ich probier's mal was dazu zu sagen.
Okay, dann lasst mich das mal durchlesen.
Jetzt hab ich gelesen, dass unter anderem mein zweitbester Kumpel und ein Kumpel, der schon mit meiner anderen Ex zusammen war und noch ein paar andere Freundinnen ihr Bild geliked haben.
Was soll ich dir dazu denn jetzt sagen?
Jetzt ist der Text leider abgehackt, mehr sieht man nicht.
Danach hört der Text auf.
Was weiß ich warum?
Warum joint eigentlich keiner von den Leuten hier? In der Admin-Konsole sind wir jetzt schon acht, na fast, jetzt sind wir wieder nur fünf Leute.
Joint mal Server, sonst können wir nicht anfangen.
Aber was auch immer genau deine Frage ist, wer da irgendwen auf Facebook liket oder sich irgendwas anguckt oder was auch immer, ich würd mal nicht allzu viel drauf geben.
Vieles in geschriebener Form wirkt immer, oder sag mal so vieles online wirkt immer schlimmer als es eigentlich in echt ist.
Also ich muss jetzt mal gucken ob mein Video freigeschaltet wurde.
Ja, a million ways das stimmt.
Online wird alles viel heißer gekocht als es letztendlich ist.
Deswegen ist es auch immer problematisch wenn man irgendwelche Mädels hat die man nur online kennt bzw. online kennengelernt hat.
Und wenn du dann noch eine hast die quasi online so, wisst ihr, es gibt dann so diese Hihi-Fraktion die zu allem Hihi schreibt und so versucht so besonders so auf, besonders so Girl-mäßig rüber zu kommen.
Und wenn du dann irgendwen sagst, ja hier lass uns doch mal, lass uns mal eben treffen machen, lass uns mal irgendwas machen.
Und dann anfangen gleich irgendeinen Drama zu machen nur weil du das mal gefragt hast, dann ist es am besten in der Regel gleich zu sagen, hier komm, auf so ein Stress hab ich echt keinen Nerv.
So, oh jetzt hat er noch einen zweiten Teil seiner Nachricht geschickt.
Eine Sache hat natürlich, das stimmt schon, eine Sache, ein Vorteil hat das online schon, man ist da, je nachdem was man so für ein Typ ist, fällt einem online einiges leichter, das ist ganz klar.
Ähm, WWPD, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob du das ernst meinst, aber wie gesagt, ich kann dir nur zu viel zu sagen, nimm das nicht so ernst was da online irgendwo auf Facebook oder sonst wo passiert.
Und fühl dich schon gar nicht angepisst wegen irgendwas was auf Facebook ist oder weil irgendwie irgendjemand anderes geliked hat auf Facebook oder so.
Man interpretiert in Online Sachen viel zu viel rein, die es eigentlich gar nicht wert sind, dass man sich da lange darüber Gedanken macht.
Du siehst die. Was? Ja der entschärft, ich wusste gar nicht, dass da noch einer drinne ist. Der ist, da ist noch einer links.
Oder auch nicht. Wir müssen jetzt mal hier runter. Seh da mal hoch Alter, seh da hoch. Was? Moment, wie hat er mich genau getroffen?
Please, please explain. Headsplitz. Ich leg wahrscheinlich so doof in der Ecke, dass man nicht gerätzt werden kann.
Und was man, was ich auch noch zu dieser ganzen Online-Geschichte sagen muss, jetzt mal, jetzt nicht jetzt auf irgendwie die Mädels oder sonst was bezogen,
so mal durch die Bank weg. Wer online ein richtiger Spaß tritt, ist meistens auch offline ein richtiger Spaß.
Online Spaß gleich offline Spaß trifft es zu 99%. Es gibt Leute, die sind online nett und in echt irgendwie merkwürdig, ja.
Das kommt vor, aber die meisten Leute, die online richtige Idioten sind, sind es auch in echt. Ich hab noch keinen getroffen,
wo ich online gedacht hab, mann was ein Spaß ist. So ein Richter, der sagt, mit dem willst du auf keinen Fall was zu tun haben.
Und dann in echt so, oh der ist aber nett. Online Spaß gleich offline Spaß.
So, jetzt muss ich mal ein bisschen anstrengen. Hi, ist Cedric.
Was soll das Krummel heißen? Plus ohne U oder I.
Ich vergess immer, dass man sich den Betten viel dreien nicht lehnen konnte.
Komm her, komm her, Kopf raus.
Mal gucken, dass er nicht wiederbelebt wird.
Wieso spielst du eigentlich Battlefield 3 und nicht Battlefield 1? Weil mir Battlefield 1 nicht gefällt.
Was? Wo kommt der denn her? Oh fuck. Jawoll, nice.
Ich hör rechts was rennen. Nachher können wir aus der Hüfte umspringen, aber nicht.
Was gefällt dir in Battlefield 1 denn nicht? Okay, da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen ausholen.
Ich hab Battlefield 1 zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, also sprich so wie es jetzt ist, hab ich nicht gespielt.
Weil ich hab mir das Game nicht gekauft nach der Beta.
Was mir in der Beta nicht gefallen hat, war unser anderem Rush.
Und ihr wisst, Rush ist für mich der Modus im Battlefield, worauf es ankommt.
Mir ist auch klar, dass es viele andere sind, deswegen ist es halt nur meine Ansicht der Dinge.
Viele finden Conquest ist eh das wichtigste und beste im Battlefield.
Okay, jedem das seine. Was mir gar nicht gefallen war Rush.
Das wirkte einfach nur hingekleistert auf die Maps, wo es eigentlich nicht hingehör.
Und das Waffenhandling hat mir lustigerweise auch nicht gefallen.
Zum Beispiel, was mir gar nicht gefallen hat, ist diese Mechanik, dass man je länger man schießt, genauer wird.
Und dass bei den Assault Rifles die Schüsse nicht dahin gehen, wo man hinzieht.
Please learn to play. Cooler Name.
Bei solchen Namen hab ich mir immer gleich instant Gedanken, ob da alles für das rechte Ding zugibt.
Go, go!
Den kann ich nicht retzen Kollegen, das geht nicht.
Jawoll! So und jetzt gehen wir vor und bashen den, der ihn retzt.
Ich krieg aber gerade Frischtmega auf die Fresse.
Und aber auch mehr.
Das sind ein bisschen viele.
Lieber Battlefield 5 oder Bad Company 3.
Allerdings nur, wenn es auch ein wirkliches, echtes Bad Company ist.
Und nachdem DICE ja selbst sagt, sie haben keine Ahnung,
was so ein ordentliches Bad Company ausmacht, was ich übrigens von ihrer Funktion nach der Auslede halte.
Ich könnte ihnen da gerne auf die Sprünge helfen.
Ich fürchte, dass es eh nur eine faule Auslede ist und sie eigentlich aus irgendwelchen Gründen das nicht machen wollen.
Zumindest kein echtes Bad Company.
Das ist ein absolutes Lieblingsspiel.
Im Nachhinein betrachtet das Spiel, wo ich am längsten Zeitrenne verbracht habe
und am meisten so involviert und engaged war, wie man das immer so schlimmt, ist Dark Age of Camelot MMO.
Aber ob man das Ding letztlich kaputt ist?
Brauche ich noch einen, der mitfährt?
Deswegen würde ich sagen, bestes Game.
Der Typ will mich abschießen.
Das kann er aber gerne mal probieren.
Alter!
Der hat aber gut gehofft.
Der hat reingehauen.
Ich habe die Gegner übrigens gesehen.
Doch, Mr. Fry Guy.
Aus da kenne ich den Friseur.
Also sieht man, man kann auch online Leute kennenlernen, die gescheit sind.
Kommt die Musik von Max, ja.
Geläuft im Hintergrund.
Wir müssten das Ganze hier mal ordentlich machen.
Wir stehen übelst beschissen.
Und ein bisschen mehr Leute müssen noch draufkommen.
Hast du die Donation Point gesehen? Nee.
Ich werde gleich noch mal gucken.
Sobald ich hier ein bisschen in Sicherheit bin.
Und ich über Gefahr laufe, ihn zu verrecken.
Ich weiß nicht, wo der...
Ja, der stirbt natürlich, das ist klar.
Und jetzt springt er nicht.
Bestes, bestes Hubsystem.
Ich hole dich, ich hole dich, ich hole dich.
Hau auf, hau auf, hau auf.
Ich gucke mir, erinnere mich bitte noch mal dran an Donation.
Falls gleich vergessen.
Der Typ, der trifft aber ziemlich gut hier.
Seiner Schnibber.
Was ist das letzte Spiel, was ich auf der Konsole gespielt habe?
Das neue Uncharted.
Ich kriege aber gerade auf die Fresse.
Trommelbrötchen 2.
Jetzt haben wir auch noch einen Scherf, das passt nicht.
Du glaubst an Bad Company wird es sich schlechter verkaufen als in Battlefield 5?
Kann sein.
Was geht denn hier gerade ab?
What the fuck?
Mit ihm stimmt fast nichts.
Da stimmt fast nichts.
Da stimmt was nicht, das sind ganz schön gute Hits hier.
Ja, Patrick macht das.
So, Donation ohne Message.
3 Euro von Vandal.
Danke für die 3 Euro.
War da wirklich keine Message dabei?
Oder zeigt es mir einfach TP Stream nicht an?
Der Name war hier, please learn to play.
Ne, ne, ne.
Schmeißt den mal raus, mit ihm stimmt was nicht.
Das ist mir gar zu hohe Genauigkeit.
Wie viele Fidget Spinner hast du?
Ist das überhaupt noch ein Ding Fidget Spinner?
Hast du keine Ahnung, was du schreiben sollst?
Danke für die 3 Euro.
Im Fall schreibt ihn in den Mist rein.
Moment, Moment, was ist hier los?
Müssen wir bashen.
Wo sind hier welche?
War mehr, streckt den Kopf raus.
Das wird nie was.
Oder, hat er es jetzt getroffen?
Okay, Kollege, runter.
War das hier der Stream-Snipe?
Ich bin hängen geblieben.
Der kann nichts.
Auf was ich mich freue, ist das neue Mario.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Da muss ich mir erst mal Gedanken über machen.
Sie gehen gerade so krass auf die Fresse.
Du musst einmal im Task-Manager abschießen.
Da bin ich jetzt hier gesportet.
Ich bin jetzt hier gesportet.
Ich treffe nichts, ich treffe nichts und die anderen treffen übelst gut.
Das ist der Name, das Level, die Hits.
Das ist echt verdächtig.
Wollt ihr wiederbeleben?
Guckt euch jemand von euch Overwatch Contenders Finals?
Ich muss ja sagen, mir ging übelst einer ab, als ich gestern gesehen habe, dass Seagull für Envy am Start war.
Aber richtig ging mir einer ab.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch da ging.
Da liegt ja noch einer.
Habt ihr den hier?
Den noch holen?
Das war doch...
Ja, ja, richtig, richtig.
Einmal über die Telekom-Leitung stream ich.
Über die Unity-Media-Leitung habe ich hauptsächlich als Backup.
Und dann mal die Anbildung von der Telekom wieder irgendwo hin besonders beschissen ist.
Wie viel stockt das Game zwischendurch ein bisschen? Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist.
Auf jeden Fall nicht, nein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob hier noch einer ist.
Guck mal, hier am Top da.
Moment, haben die uns den Panzer geklaut? Na toll.
Perfekt.
Von welcher Seite könnte hier was kommen?
Ich wusste, dass der jetzt rangeht. Das wäre die Chance gewesen, den Typ zu baschen.
Ab wann kann man subscriben, weiß ich schon nicht genau.
Ich habe auch noch keine grossartigen Ambitionen.
Weil das schafft immer so Druck irgendwie.
Jetzt haben wir eine gute Parkverteilung.
Das schafft immer so Druck, wenn man ein Subbutton hat.
Das schafft immer so Druck, dass man denkt, ich muss jetzt.
Weil es eigentlich blöd sind.
Müssen wir den Panzer baschen.
Ich muss jetzt gerade noch mal ein bisschen hier umstellen an den Options.
Das Game, das hat immer irgendwie so Slowding.
Ich bin so pummisch.
Gucken ob es jetzt besser ist.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Popo klatschen ist auf den Zauber gekommen.
Wie weit sind die denn? Bin ich schon aufgerückt?
Ich habe Visung an, ernsthaft? Hab ich?
Nee, hab ich nicht. Hab ich wirklich?
Das muss weg.
Ich habe Visung an.
Visung in 2K17.
Ja, jetzt ist es viel besser.
Ah, fuck. Scheiße.
Wie konnte er denn damit rechnen?
Visung, LOL. Kann man sich bei euch schon umreden? Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich noch.
Ich bin auf der Straße.
Streamer mit Subbutton werden immer schlechter. Nee, finde ich nicht.
Das finde ich nicht, dass Streamer mit Subbutton immer schlecht.
Warum soll Streamer mit Subbutton immer schlechter werden?
Ich meine, es hat ja je nachdem, wie sehr man darauf angewiesen ist und sowas, sorgt es teilweise eher dafür, dass es eine regelmäßige Streams-Schedule gibt und alles.
Also, ich würde sagen, eigentlich finde ich es eher positiv, die Leute, die den Button haben, wie die sich entwickelt haben.
Gott, ist das eine chaotische Runde.
Ich bin zum Beispiel großer Taimou-Fan auf fast jedem Stream, auch wenn ich on bin und Taimou on ist.
Er ist auch genauso wie früher, als er bloß 200 Leute zugeguckt hat.
PMA.
Sag mal, wie krass ich gerade auf den Sack kriege. Meine Güte.
Ja, Custer kann man sich auch gut geben, weil Taimou ist anscheinend mein Lieblings-Overwatch-Streamer.
Das ist die chaotischste Runde Battlefield 3, die ich seit langem gespielt habe.
Ach, das ist so durcheinander, Wahnsinn.
Die haben ja schon wieder den Panzer geklaut, was machen die? Ah ne, doch nicht.
Da hat man das Gefühl, der wird ein bisschen gestream sniped.
Ich wollte eigentlich reintappen mit dem Defi und dann direkt um die Ecke gehen, aber das war keine so gute Idee.
Kannste da drüberspringen?
Alter, sprayt die halt weg?
Sprayt sie weg?
Tja, wer jetzt hinter uns rumgehampelt ist, dann hat der...
So, weiter, weiter, weiter.
Ich hoffe, da kommt jetzt nichts.
Yolo, Yolo.
Achso, wir haben den anderen ja schon.
TS oder Discord, gibts sowas?
Meinst du Max FPS Discord? Nee, gibts noch nicht.
Ist seit gefühlt 2 Jahren geplant, oder seit einem halben Jahr.
So, fresh in FTW.
Ich hol dich, ich hol dich, ich hol dich.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Aber das war... von hinten kommt ein Panzer. Der Pantsman ist back.
Der Pantsman ist back.
Warum haben die immer unseren Panzer?
Leute, passt doch mal auf.
Da haut er rein, der Popo-Klatscher.
ACR können wir auch mal ne Runde spielen.
Bei ACR ist ne... eine Medikwaffe... eine... Ingenieurwaffe, ne?
Da ist der Typ.
Der Eiskäuter macht das. Falls ihr irgendwelche Fragen überlesen habt, schreibt es aber noch mal.
Was ist denn hier los?
Wo sind die denn?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo die denn sind.
Willst du die DLC-Stories spielen für das neue Zelda? Ist nicht ein DLC sogar schon raus? War da nicht irgendwas?
Ich bilde mir ein, ein DLC ist schon raus.
Nee, werd ich nicht. Aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Auch wenn man das Hauptspiel Bock gemacht hat.
Oder sagen wir mal so, je nachdem was Nintendo macht.
Du stehst ganz natürlich nur zufällig jetzt da, nicht weil du im Stream geguckt hast oder so, ne?
Das ist nur ein Challenge-Modus und ein Master-Schwert-Steiger zum Mania, den hab ich nicht gespielt.
Also falls es wirklich den guten neuen Story-Modus gibt, dann bin ich wahrscheinlich auch wieder am Start.
Was den Teufel trifft mich denn hier? Was trifft mich denn hier? Ach, da drüben.
Das ist wirklich eines der chaotischsten Rollen, die ich lange gespielt hab.
Und ich glaube, ich muss mal einen Delay-End-Stream machen.
Haha, ihr trefft doch eh nicht. Ups.
Ich dachte, die sind alle vorbeigeflogen. Lul.
Der Helikopter-Rust ist auch schon wieder am Flamen.
Wo kült der denn her? Ganz ganz komische Frame-Drops hier.
Ganz ganz komische Frame-Drops.
Nope. Fuck.
Muss ich ein bisschen höher ziehen, sonst hätte ich die alle umgesprayt.
Hoffentlich versucht mich keiner zu retzen.
Oh Leute, rein da, rein da, rein da. Gretzen rein da.
Granaten drauf, Granatenspam.
Kein Schärf, nope.
Labe Runde, Labe Runde.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass sich Battlefront ganz gut verkaufen wird.
Auch wenn mich das Gameplay überhaupt nicht überzeugt hat, ihr habt es ja im Stream gesehen.
Wirklich ist es so ein sehr uninspiriertes 0815 zweite Teile, wie ich je gesehen habe.
Also wirklich ein ziemlicher Mist. Aber das hat eine ordentliche Lizenz.
Das wird sich auf jeden Fall gut verkaufen.
Ich hab die Runde verloren, ich war der letzte Tod.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Battlefront lange Zeit gespielt wird.
Das spielt nach ein paar Wochen keiner mehr.
Ich geb dem Gamer zur Prediction, ich geb dem Gamer einen Monat.
Mal gucken.
Warum ist mein Browser so langsam?
Und warum geht das Video nicht mehr direkt auf, wenn man das im Video Manager anguckt?
Sachen, die muss man nicht verstehen.
Weil Google sich gedacht hat, so ist das, so ist das richtig.
Hast du früher Battlefield 2 gezockt?
Nee, kaum, kaum, ganz, ganz wenig.
Battlefield 2 ging fast komplett an mir vorbei.
Aber das war eine Zeit, wo ich wahrscheinlich da auch 24-7 gespielt habe.
Ups, geht ja schon los.
Es ruckelt, was denn hier los?
Ich glaub, ich muss das Gang gleich mal neu starten.
Scheiß auf A, Scheiß auf A.
Hätte der Defi das erste Mal funktioniert, wär ich durchgekommen.
Ich wusste, dass du rechts guckst.
Wir müssen aufpassen, von rechts kommt da noch was.
Ach, die sind schon alle weg.
Wir müssen aber gucken, dass von rechts keiner kommt.
Guck mal da, paar sollten von rechts gucken zumindest.
Andere Seite, andere Seite, andere Seite.
Oh fuck, rechts, rechts, rechts.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp.
Alter.
Ist da noch was?
Ich seh da nix.
Aber ja, die machen's richtig, so musst du's machen.
Thomas, das machen schön von beiden Seiten, musst du da ran.
Was hältst du eigentlich von Werbung in anderen Streams?
Du meinst Leute, die in andere Streams gehen, um da ihren eigenen Stream zu spammen?
Find ich gut gedacht.
Also, wenn du gehostet wirst, das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Das find ich sogar gut, dass es das gibt.
Aber in anderen Streams rumspammen, so nach dem Motto kommt man hier vorbei,
und das ist wirklich beknackt.
Richtig bescheuert.
Er ist vom Germany.
Da kann einer durchgelaufen.
Die spammen ja aber übelst rum.
Ich will den retzen.
Rechts.
Der will ja bestimmt wieder retzen.
Zack, in den Kopf rein.
So muss das sein.
Nicht so weit vor, Leute, nicht so weit vor.
No, einfach play Tournaments.
Just play casual.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, eigentlich würde ich erwarten, dass die von der Mitte kommen.
Fuck.
Kacke aller Kiste hängen geblieben.
Wir müssen in die Mitte, in den mittleren Gang, da müssen wir rein.
Könntest du vielleicht mal später CTF spielen?
Es gab Capture the Flag in Battlefield 3.
Habst du das?
Wirklich?
Was?
Oh, Noob Tube.
Wenn er Capture the Flag, spielt wahrscheinlich kein Mensch mehr hier drinnen.
Das spielt wahrscheinlich keiner mehr.
Ich hole euch, Jungs, ich hole euch.
Okay.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, Jungs.
Go, go, go hier.
Die Fusen.
Ich gucke nach rechts, das kriegst du.
Mal einfach mal hier Prefire auf die Ecke.
So, und jetzt in den Gang in die Mitte.
Backbashing.
Backed.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, wo sie herkommen.
Wir finden sie in Battlefield 1, das ist nicht mein Fall.
Ich habe ja die Beta gespielt.
Hätte ich damals schon gestreamt, hätte ich auch die Beta gestreamt.
Hat mir nicht gefallen.
Oh, der Panzer.
Wie gesagt, werde ich ja fast jeden Stream öfters gefragt, vorhin auch schon.
Rush hat mir nicht gefallen in Battlefield 1.
Und das Waffenhändling hat mir nicht gefallen.
Mir haben auch die Fahrzeuge nicht gefallen.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Die hässlichen Panzer da.
Mag sein, dass die Dinge am ersten Weltkrieg so ausgeschaut haben.
Aber ich glaube, es ist nicht so.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht so.
Ich habe jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass hier einer herkommt.
Aber kommt keiner her?
Muss hier aber sein.
Nice.
Crystal Pick.
ich glaube es nicht am arsch der welt am arsch der welt stehen sie rum
müssen zurück zum b
Ja ich vermiss Rush auch, Rush sackte in Battlefield 1, Rush sackte auch schon in Battlefield 4
Wobei es da erträglich war auf manchen Maps
Ich finde man muss auch nicht Rush und Conquest uns auf jeder Map anbieten
Ich glaube es hätte keiner was dagegen wenn es quasi, sagen wir mal jetzt, es gibt 16 große Conquest Maps
Und davon gibt es bloß 10 in Rush, vielleicht auch eigene Rush Maps
Beziehungsweise vielleicht die Conquest Maps sogar halt ein bisschen umgebaut
Dass sie sich gut für Rush eignen, nur ein kleiner Teil davon
Da hätte glaube ich keiner was dagegen, es muss ja nicht auf jeder Conquest Map Rush gehen
Jetzt kommt glaube ich keiner in den Gang
Bringt ja auch nix, genauso wie es für TDM und die ganzen anderen Grenzen in Battlefield kaum einer spielt
Man könnte es auch entweder eigene Maps geben oder angepasste Versionen
Es müssen nicht exakt die gleichen Maps sein, entsprechend muss doch gar null, warum?
Es könnte von Grant Bazaar eine Conquest Version geben oder eine Rush Version zum Beispiel
Also man gibt es in dem Fall auch, es ist die gleiche
Weil der einfach gute Map ist
Was haben wir denn hier im Gegner überhaupt? Kann man das mal erklären?
Ich habe Schiss vor dem Panzer
Kuyasu, genauso war das auch
Und vor allem bei meiner Freundesliste, wo ich immer, ich habe jeden Tag fast Battlefield 3 gespielt damals
Freundesliste geguckt, alle am Start gewesen
Battlefield 3 ein Jahr nach Release quasi, Battlefield 3 gespielt
Durch die Bank 90% der Leute, die ich über das Game kannte, immer noch aktiv
Alle dann gewechselt zu Battlefield 4 und nach zwei Wochen keine Säume on
Geil, ne?
Wie findest du Pupke?
Es ist spannend gemacht, aber mir erschließt sich der Hype um Battle Royale nicht so wirklich
Ich kann nur nicht verstehen, dass jetzt alle auf Fortnite und so so abgehen
Battle Royale, wie gesagt, ich verstehe den Hype da drunter gar nicht
Es ist spannend, ja, das ist auch ganz nett
Aber in meinem Fall ist das nicht
Spielen übrigens auf dem PC ungefähr nur ein Drittel weniger Battlefield 4 als Battlefield 1
Aber wir fahren Panzer
Neues Bad Company wäre nice, aber halt ein richtiges Bad Company
Richtig geile Rushmaps, wo man sich nicht hinlegen kann, so wie mal was man halt unter Bad Company erwartet
Ich hätte vielleicht als Engineer spawnen sollen
Kann leider nicht
Jolo, Jolo, Jolo, komm her, du siehst keiner
Hinter mir
Tja, damit hast du mich gereicht
Nope, nope, nope
Willst du mich flanken oder was? Willst du mich flanken?
What the fuck?
Wie viele Leute? Hilfe!
Das hätte ich als eh mitgereicht, dass da acht Leute stehen
Was hältst du vom neuen Battlefront?
Die Frage kam mir schon ein paar Mal
Meine Prediction für das neue Battlefront ist, es wird höchstens im Monat gespielt oder nach
Es wird kein gesondertes Game
Meine persönliche Meinung zu dem Game ist, es ist der, oder auch der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der
Meine persönliche Meinung zu dem Game ist, es ist der, oder eines der uninspiriertesten
Äh, so zweite Teile, Neuauflagen, langweilig vom Gameplay her, die ich gesehen habe bisher
Es macht einfach null Spaß, meine Meinung dazu
Bei mir kommt halt auch dabei, ich fokussiere mich da halt wirklich rein auf, auf das Game
Bei mir hat es halt auch kein... Hallo, kannst du sterben? Auf wieviel hätten wir noch aus?
Au, bei mir hat es keinen Star Wars Bonus, nicht geschämt
Bei mir hat es keinen Star Wars Bonus, weil ich halt kein Star Wars Fan bin
Oh, ich will mich auch nicht gut auskennen im Star Wars Universum, deswegen
Also, es kann bestimmt bei einigen durch halt eben das Star Wars Settingpunkt
Okay
Bei mir halt nicht
Ne, für Xbox spiele ich nicht mehr
700p, lol
Oder war es überhaupt 700p?
Letztlich
Mein Kollege steigt ein, falls da noch Platz drinne ist
Jetzt Battlefield 3 auf der Xbox One?
Ne, es gibt Battlefield 4, gibt es auf 360 und auf der One
Für 60
So, weiter rennen
Ich weiß nicht, hier meine ich die 60-Power aufgeladen
Jede Umdrehung zählt mehr Damage
Battlefield 3 kann man nicht auf der... Achso, ja, du kannst Battlefield 3 auf der One spielen
Mit dem 360-Kompatibilitätsmodus, das stimmt
Aber es gibt keine Battlefield-Dimension für die 360
Jetzt Blitz
Kommt Star Citizen noch in diesem Jahrhundert weg?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Star Citizen überhaupt mal rauskommt als komplettes Game
Also, aus allen Einzelteilen bestehen, dass alle Einzelteile fertig sind
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
Ja, schon Leute, schnappt euch den Panzer von uns, schnappt euch den Panzer
Guck mal, ich muss die Runde überhaupt nichts machen und wir gewinnen uns denn, easy
NAA, richtig krasses NAA
Was ich an Star Citizen gut finde, ist, dass die wenigstens die Ambitionen haben, das fertig zu machen
Es ist ja nicht so eine beschiss Kickstarter-Kampagne, sondern die meinen das ja wirklich ernst
Ich glaube aber halt nicht, dass das was wird
Fortnite habe ich noch nie gespielt
Aber wie gesagt, ich kapierte die Wette Royale halt nicht so ganz
Kann man hier noch einsteigen?
Ja, das würde mich auch nicht wundern
Wenn es noch die Dating-Simulation geben würde in Star Citizen
Wahrscheinlich ist das sogar geplant
Au, verpiss dich
Verpiss dich
Wann amüsierst du mal wieder Overwatch-Videos?
Dazu müsste ich auch mal wieder Overwatch-Videos machen
Dazu müsste ich Overwatch selbst erst wieder aktiv spielen
Und im aktuellen Meta durchblicken
Dass ich dazu qualifiziert was sagen kann
Vielleicht auch mal wieder in einem oder anderen League-League-Cup oder sowas mitspielen
Jetzt zwar nicht auf Ultra-Niveau oder so, sondern halt einfach mit ein bisschen Ambition
Dass ich wieder durchblicke
Au, war das, als ich wieder durchblicke, was da gerade angesagt ist
Lässt dich Battlefield 3 noch gut auf dem PC?
Obdicke ja nicht, ja
Lässt dich
Rätst dich Kunde, rätst dich
Hallo
Darf mich rätten
Rätst die Neid
Icecoiter, ich weiß nicht, also
Wenn du mir Overwatch-Videos geschickt hast
Dann werde ich die wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit nicht verwenden, zum anderen wie hier
Ich habe halt einfach keinen Durchblick gerade in Overwatch
Also außer so das, was jeder weiß, dass Mercy Probe my fuck ist
Und man sich fragt, was die Blizzard-Balancing-Abteilung mit dem neuen Mercy Patch bezwecken wollte
Alter
Schreckt, schreckt er wieder
Ich hatte genauso viel Spass, tschüss.
Backen!
Kommt her!
Hier, beste, beste
Glitch-Position hier oben.
Nice.
Ja, Patrick, da hat er ein bisschen überreagiert.
Das schafft kein Plan, meiner Ansicht nach.
Also, wer es nicht mitgekriegt hat,
es hat jemand im Forum geschrieben,
passt übrigens gut zum Video,
was ich heute hochgeladen habe.
Es hat ihn dann ein bisschen überreagiert,
das schafft kein Plan, meiner Ansicht nach.
Also, wer es nicht mitgekriegt hat,
es hat jemand im Forum geschrieben,
das schafft kein Plan, meiner Ansicht nach.
Also, wer es nicht mitgekriegt hat,
es hat jemand im Forum geschrieben,
dass sich das Balancing-Team von Blizzard
neue Jobs suchen soll,
dass sie ausgetauscht werden sollen,
oder so was in der Richtung.
Da kam mal Chef Kaplan als Aufbauwort Chef an,
hat gesagt, hier, sowas verlangt keiner
und quasi Forum-Bann.
Es war ein bisschen überreagiert,
weil es so Leute sind, die so lange
bei dem Game dabei sind.
Obwohl es ihnen so viel auf den Sack geht,
Aber Jeff ist ja da bekannt dafür, dass er früher selbst mal ein bisschen online rumgeraged hat, weiß nicht ob ihr das wisst, da war früher quasi einer, ich weiß nicht ob Gildenleiter oder ob nur in der Top EverQuest-Gilde dabei, also quasi High-End, High-End Raid EverQuest Content hat er gemacht und ist da bekannt dafür, dass er öfters auch im Forum rumgeflamet hat, das war auch der Grund dafür, dass ihn Blizzard damals eingestellt hat.
Um an World of Warcraft mitzuarbeiten, weil man wusste das ist jemand, der weiß wie PvE-Encounter auszusehen haben, also es ist auch für eine Hersteller nicht schlecht mal auf gute Spieler zu hören.
Fahr mit! Oh ich bin beim Helikopter-Russel dabei, das fängt schon gut an. Danke Hans!
Bam, bam, bam! Hinter uns ist ein Amtrak. Nur mal so angemerkt, hinter uns ist ein Amtrak.
Hinter uns sind wir noch am Amtrak. Vielleicht möchte der Panzer den Amtrak hinter uns killen. Der lebt noch, er könnte gleich leben. Au! Au!
Vielleicht werden wir, ich muss weg. Vielleicht werden wir gerettet.
Ja genau, Eiskreuter. Kann ich noch Jeffka planen? Tigole oder wie man ihn ausspricht. Wo ist das Auto? Hallo Auto, wie wärs mal mit kaputt gehen? Der wird uns in die Luft jagen.
Das mag ich, das ist das beste an Battlefield 3, dass man endlich mal durch Leute durchschießen kann.
Lass mich wieder einsteigen. Oh so viele Leute zu bashen. Alter rekt. Shrek, rectangle, erect, Tyrannosaurus rekt, alles zusammen.
Na wo kommt denn das Auto? Wo kommt das Auto lang? Komm her!
Komm her Auto! Bam! Bam! Ich sehs nicht mehr.
Du du du du du du du du.
Wenn du sagst, ich will anschalten spielen, dann go go.
Die Gegner werden ziemlich ins Ball gedrückt gerade. Jetzt soll ich sich weiter retten.
Knack 2 ist das gut, der erste Teil war nicht so toll.
Ist klar, da sterb ich auch nie, wenn ich 5 was weiß ich wie viel fettes Kaliber Geschoss abkrieg.
Komm jetzt mal hinter den Stein raus. Jetzt reichts. Ah gut, ich wollte gerade aussteigen.
Ihr sehts umlinks, Sniper Limit aufgesäuert. Wichtigste Sache überhaupt.
Ja Leute, reparier du, ich schieße.
Wir sind übrigens noch nicht ganz. Wir müssen mal zurück zu A.
Sieht für mich so aus, als ist da gerade jemand an A dran.
Nein, Kollege.
Problem ist, da steht der Amtrak davor.
Einfach durchgezogen.
Mbp.
Hau ab, Panzer.
Ich glaube, den kann ich nicht wiederbeleben.
Dann lässt du mich wieder einsteigen.
Okay, da ist schon einer.
Der Mk Buben gehts gut. Den war ich vor 2 Wochen in Asier-Olien.
Bei dem ist alles in der Sorte.
Da kommt ein Amtrak. Das gefällt mir nicht.
Total bescheuertes Position.
Ich glaube, ich spawn mal als Engineer rein.
Sebaro willst du sagen, das ist anders.
Natürlich bin ich der beste Rush-Spieler.
KD ist alles. Der beste KD hat automatisch bester Spieler.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal richtig MVP-Plays.
Wenn das kein MVP-Play ist, dann weißt du.
Du hast MVP-Plays, oder?
Das war wirklich ein gutes Play am Ende.
Wäre das geil gewesen, hätte ich schon 3 Zeiten gestreamt.
Stellt euch mal vor, wie es hier abgegangen wäre, wenn das Game im Hype noch gewesen wäre.
Gab es überhaupt Twitch schon 2011? Ja, naja, gab es schon. Gerade so.
Sebaro habe ich schon.
Genau, so sieht es aus.
Weiß jemand, wann Contenders losgehen, muss ich nachher gucken.
Twitch-TV ist quasi die Gaming-Spart von JustinTV geworden.
Kack-Map, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist meine ungeliebteste Battle-For-Try-Map hier.
Ich muss euch mal loben an der Stelle.
Ich kenne keinen Chat auf Twitch, der bei 125 Zuschauern.
So aktiv ist und gleichzeitig so angenehm ist, wie meiner.
War es natürlich auch mal ein Mod-Flip.
Die wenig moderieren mussten, aber selbst mit-spammen können.
Ist das nicht getroffen, oder was?
Steckt.
Okay, da macht er schon.
Mit der Arm-Prust, was geht mit dem ab?
Captain, was das Zeug hält.
Das ging aber lang.
Wo ist der Chat?
Gebatet, gebatet.
Ja, ich hätte noch 360 machen müssen, das ist wichtig.
360 wären jetzt noch wichtig gewesen.
Moment.
Was ist das hier?
What the fuck?
Alter.
Das ist schon ewig her.
Irgendwo, wo Deckung ist.
Au.
Wo ist er hin?
Da ist der Chebader.
Da geht er jetzt in die Tür rein.
War so klar einfach, dass du in die Tür reingehst.
Null.
Da ist noch einer.
Wenn die entschärfen, läuft das auf die Fresse.
Oder auch nicht.
Scheiße.
What the fuck?
Alter, wie viele sind das denn?
Das heißt, wir machen das nur noch.
Ja, Büffel, das verstehe ich bis heute nicht, warum das Video aus dem Garten so viele Views hat.
Also ich weiß, warum es so viele Views hat, weil YouTube der Meinung war, es muss auf der Startseite promoted werden.
Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum.
Ich hätte bestimmt, keine Ahnung, 80k Abos oder irgendwas gekriegt, wenn die was Gescheites mal promoted hätten.
Mit 2,5 Millionen Views, aber nee.
Video im Garten.
Da.
Ja, der Pfeiffer ist jetzt vom Killerspiel mittlerweile umgestiegen, das habe ich ja auch gesehen.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf Killerspieler, für den ist mittlerweile das Gaming zu normal.
Hallo?
Ich darf nichts, ja.
Red Splitz.
Also generell Shooter interessieren heute keine Sau mehr.
Das juckt da keinen mehr.
Da regt sich auch keiner mehr drüber auf.
RTL bringt keine komischen Beiträge mehr.
Das ist vorbei.
Fuck.
Ich dachte, ich kann auch so liegen.
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Red Splitz.
Ich kann auch von unten retzen, kein Problem.
Mülltonnen mit Spielentsorgung gibt es auch nicht, nein.
Warte, warte, warte.
Warum hast du nicht auf Defi geswitcht, Alter?
Warum?
Gedrückt.
Du darfst mitspielen, einfach auf den Server joinen.
Warum haben wir es eigentlich nicht geschafft, das einzunehmen?
Ich habe hier die Klasse MVP Plays am Anfang.
Es ist der GG, weiter gehts.
Der Friseur war gestern live in BDO, ja, war er.
Was ist er hier? Falls er online ist, den müssen wir raiden nachher. Falls er online ist.
Das ist der Channel vom Frisör. Ja, der ist ziemlich oft online. Aber gerade nicht.
Also, wenn man mitspielen will, hier ist der Server. Oh, das muss man wieder hinsetzen. Ich habe hier
wieder mein Stehschreibtisch am Start. Also das Ding, was man hochfahren kann. Seit Start des Streams bin ich am Stehen.
Der streamt sogar mit Webcam. Der Frasier.
Ja, ich stehe gerade zu spielen. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig, wenn der Arm nach unten hängt fürs Aim.
Aber das ist für den Rücken entspannter.
Ich will in den Panzer rein.
Ha, ich habe nie diesen Ping.
Achtung! Fuck, so hoch kann ich nicht schießen.
Ne. Treffer. Bäm. Schreckt. Bäm. Oh, das hätte treffen müssen. Wo ist das Auto?
Moment, wie haben die das schon gesetzt?
Ja, denn haben unsere Chat nicht platt gemacht. Der eigene Chat ist wichtig, um zumindest die Gegner so weit zu beschäftigen, dass er nicht die ganze Zeit Panzer killen kann, sonst kommt man hier nicht weiter.
Warte mal schon, wenn ich sehe, warum er mich geschossen hat.
Achtung! Bäm. Oh. Skillshot aus der Hüfte.
Nix war's.
Ist doch noch jemand in Bad Company. Ich habe vor ein paar Wochen im Stream Bad Company 2 gespielt. Es gibt eigentlich genug Server, wo noch was los ist.
Wir decken uns mal, oder?
Au.
Übrigens, für alle, die es noch nicht wussten, die Treppe geht nicht kaputt. Man kann hier so lange stehen, wie man will.
Ich kann hier so lange stehen, wie man will.
Die überraschen uns ja.
Das ist eine richtige Überraschung.
Wo kam der dann her?
Stop tank stealing play fair. Warum wer sich den Tank klauen lässt und so blöde ist, da kannst du dir halt echt nichts machen.
Hier haben wir mal genug Luftabwehr, ne?
Du du du du du du du du du du du du du du. Auf! Du du du du du.
Kein Hit.
Ich renn jetzt dem Heli nach
Ist der Heli abgestürzt?
Ich seh nix mehr
Komm her!
Hallo?
Ist man das von da unten? Ich war mir gar nicht klar
Der Streamtitel triggert? Warum triggert er?
Warum kann man den Chat nicht erfassen?
Außerdem ist Battlefield 3 best ever, Alter lan!
Da weht schon ein Christophel
Skillwaffe im Einsatz
Jetzt müsste ein unser Chatten Typ baschen
Ich habe einen Gegner getroffen
Gegner getroffen!
Battlefield 3 ist das Beste!
Ich hab den Gegner auf den Typ drauf geflogen
Teil 4 ist mittlerweile auch ein gutes Game
Also DICE hat sich da echt zusammen gerissen nach dem Kackstart
Und aus Battlefield 4 ein gutes Spiel gemacht
Leider ist es Battlefield 4 und Battlefield 3
Ich halt immer noch finde ich viel zu ähnlich
Als dass es ein vierter Teil hätte sein müssen
Oh nee, ich hab hier...
Ich hab kein Panzerabwehr mehr dabei
Ja, Kenny seh ich genauso
Battlefield 4, drei Jahre später, perfekt
Wo sind denn die Gegner?
Was schärft die Scheiße?
Alter, Alter!
Ja, das ist zwar ein eigener Battlefield 3
Aber teure, teure Uhren
Krebsen mich ja eigentlich schon
Bbbb
Na dann공 abholen
Hab jetzt rausges...
Oah, Facebook dachte er hat ihn rausgesn zajp
Das war nix
Fahrzeugslaufen sind immer nicht verkehrt
Ich hol dich, ich hol dich
Ich hol euch besser gesagt
Fuck
Ich hol dich besser gesagt
Aua
Komm her
Kommt her Leute, kommt her
Mann, wie haben sie das jetzt gemacht
Alter Mann, hin
Was?
Von wo haben die mich getroffen?
Jetzt plötzlich
Hallo, springen
Direkt
Der Red Strain
Das ist das geilste an dem Game
Die sollen halt wieder Spiele machen, die ordentlich
Weißt du, die haben bei Battlefield 4
Bei Battlefield 1, bei HF
Die haben so viel rumgeschwallt
Von dem Battlefield hier, Battlefield da
Die sollen ein Game machen, was Battlefield hat
Und nicht wo man drüber reden muss
Sondern einfach ein Game, was es hat
Hol dich
Das geht so ab, Battlefield 3
So ein geiles Game
Ja, Kartendoll, ich denke auch, dass man mit
der 1080 Ti mehr packen würde
Aber das Schöne ist, in Battlefield, man hat mit weniger
Details, sieht man schlicht mehr
Was sehr praktisch ist
Moment
Jawoll
Die
Dass wir das noch gewonnen haben, ich weiß auch nicht warum
Die Nade Optik, die war
gar nicht NA, die war absichtlich
In den Ritz schmeißen
Das Game wird gleich wieder erfolgt, ich muss doch gerade mal auf Youtube gucken
Creeping Death?
Hast du? 31,5
Eindeutig
Hast du?
Seine Crossing
Ich weiß, dass es nicht seine heißt
Nur so angemerkt
Aber es hat sich so eingebürgelt, dass man sagt
Seine Crossing
Außerdem
Muss man nicht unbedingt Sachen
Französisch aussprechen
Franzloll
Wir müssen die abfangen
und vor so einer Straße gehen
Und warum sterben die nicht?
Loll
Fuck, weiter
Scheiße
Was ist hier was? Ich sehe nichts
Oh
Ich dachte, der wollte uns C4
Was ist hier was? Ich sehe nichts
Ich brauche diese Panzerbrechende
Munition
Das wichtigste hier für das LRW
Damit haut man ja alles kaputt
Oh nee
Wir retten die jetzt eh
Deswegen schließen wir gleich wieder rein
Hätten wir nicht, okay
Da links ist was
Ich sehe übrigens gerade keine Schatten
Ich glaube, es ist eine Fenster offen
Wie kann man da nicht rein?
Weiter
Kommen wir da jetzt mal rein zur Abwechslung?
Nope, kommen wir nicht rein
Weiß nicht, warum wir da nicht reingekommen sind
Ich bin Ingenieur
Wir müssen das halten
Lasst euch nicht bashen Jungs
Nice, nice, nice
Dass wir das noch gekriegt haben, richtig cool
Tab FTW
Ich habe keinen Bock Tab zu schießen
Rüber aufs Schiff
Da habe ich keinen Tipp
Das Problem habe ich auch
Da gibt es keinen Tipps
Aber ich kann dir sagen
Es ist quasi sobald du auch da bist
Nicht mal so schlimm
Hat gefragt, ob ich einen Tipp habe
Nach dem Urlaub wieder
Wenn man keinen Bock hat auf die Arbeit zu gehen
Da hat keiner Bock
Niemand hat da Bock drauf
Aber es ist nicht so schlimm
Wenn man erst mal da ist
Aber es ist einfach machst du
Jolo
Hallo?
Warum hat er sich nicht gelegt?
Jetzt haben wir das Halbmagazin in den Kopf geschossen, hier kehrst.
Go, go, rauf hier!
Oh, das sind ganz schön viele Gegner.
Oh fuck, ich hab keine Munition mehr!
Please, gegen, please!
Ammo, please!
Oh fuck, von hinten!
Lege Hände im Main, by the way!
Leere Tasten, spam! Geht der respawn schneller!
Simple geometry!
Ah!
Hüpp, hüpp, alter hüpp!
Warum sterben die grad nicht?
Werkt der wie noch? Alter, wenn die gerade jebaited!
Alter, wenn die jebaited! Habt ihr das gesehen?
Wie sie geouten wurden!
Krasser Shit! Alter, wenn die geouten waren!
Das muss ich mir speichern!
Das war eigentlich der geilste Aktion, den ich je hatte in dem Game!
Eats clap!
Was ich mir aufsetze, spiele...
Gute Frage, ich glaube, dass das Rohr...
Warte mal, ich sag's dir!
Wo sieht man das nochmal?
Das Rohr!
Griff und Codra, wie sie auch!
Fuck, da sind viele drin!
Da steht immer noch hier rum!
Übrigens, unsere Perks sacken, wir haben zweimal gleich Perks!
Die Contenders ist live! Oh Gott! Was ist denn für ein erstes Game? EU oder NA? Wahrscheinlich EU, ne?
Also Misfits gegen...
Gigantti!
Wann geht das Game los? Sag mal, ich will unbedingt Contenders scotten!
Die Baden hast du nicht jetzt!
Was wiegt vor?
Direkt von der Seite!
Wann geht Contenders los? Müsste doch jetzt bald sein!
Je mehr konnte ich da nicht machen gerade!
Machst du die Steuererklärung beziehungsweise lohnt sich das? Lohnen tut sich das auf jeden Fall!
Aber ich lass sie machen!
Ich hab da null Bock drauf! Das ist so eines der beschissenen Sachen, für mich jedes Jahr Steuererklärung gedürzt zu machen! Ich hasse es!
Obwohl es schnell geht, was ich machen muss! Ich muss ja eigentlich nur abgeben, das Zeug!
Stirbt er nicht!
Wie viel kostet es sich sowas machen zu lassen?
Wenn du eine eigene Firma hast oder keine speziellen Dinge hast, dann kostest du das wahrscheinlich auch nicht so oder wahnsinn, wahrscheinlich 150 oder 200 oder sowas je nachdem wo du bist, ich weiß nicht wie das der Satz ist.
Wenn du das mehrere Dinge machen musst, dann kann es auch mal 300, 400 kosten! Aber es ist mir immer noch lieber als den Scheiß selbst zu machen!
Ja, es geht ja!
Orts machen das Freunde bekannt! Da muss man natürlich auch keine Kohle für Orts geben! Das ist eigentlich die beste Variante!
Das ist die beste Variante!
Das sind die steigenden Fähigkeiten!
Heute läuft es ganz gut!
Das ist die beste Variante!